انا اعتقد انه في مثل هذه المسائل يختلط
الامرين لسياسه بالدين والسياسي والعقائدي
والطائفي والديني والثقافي هي مساله مركبه
ومعقده والحقيقه يعني كثير من الافكار
والاتجاهات هي تبدا في البدايه من منطلقات
سياسيه تبدا من منطلقات السياسيه ثم مع
مرور الوقت تتحول الى عقائد وهذا يعني جزء
كبير من تشكل الفرق والطوائف والمذاهب في
الاسلام في بدايتها كانت لاسباب سياسيه
وبعد ذلك تحولت الى جوانب عقائديه لكن في
جزء من هذا السجال ليس المقصود هو الشخصيه
التاريخيه القديمه احيانا هذا السجال
الطائفي الذي يغلف بانه صراعه العلاقه
شخصيه تاريخيه هو ليس من اجل الشخصيه
التاريخيه اجل مثلا اعطيك مثال حينما تسمع
مثلا في بعض الشوارع او في بعض المدن وفي
المظاهرات صيحات طائفيه او لعنات توجه
لشخصيات تاريخيه مثلا لعنات الى بني اميه
مثلا وتسمعها في بعض الشوارع وبعض المدن
هذه اللعنات او الصيحات الطائفيه هل
المقصود فيها فعلا شخصيات قديمه قبل
1400 سنه افضت الى بارئها
مقصود منه اعلان تمايز طائفي ومذهبي ترسيخ
هويه طائفيه معينه في صراعات الحاضر
يستخدم فيها التاريخ في هذا الصراع اذا
التاريخ اصبح اداه لصراعاتنا المعاصره